less sexual partners to alleviate
themselves from these traumas well no
because i just i i don't think that
alleviates women from sexual trauma but
there's a contradiction in itself
because how your past experiences have
led to current traumas so if you had
less partners obviously this is your
first boyfriend in most cases you know
the more partners you have the more
likely you are for these sort of
situations to us i've only had i've only
ever had two boyfriends
officially we've had more sexual
partners yeah yeah so my point is my
point is if we're going to go off the
premise that too many sexual partners
for women create negative situations
because of the trauma that's it that
inflicts can't you then see the logic in
saying that in your situation or
applying that logic to other people if
you have less sexual partners there is
less chance of these traumatic
experiences so less more happiness
prevails with the less partners you have
or sexual partners you have
hmm i
i can't say that i don't see a basis of
in true of truth in that
um
but i just don't feel like we should be
i just i said it's so nuanced because i
just don't feel like taking away sexual
partners brings happiness i feel like
but
it brings better results
so because don't you think it's a good
odds 80 chance of a happy marriage if
you're a virgin on your wedding night
well versus i just the average the
average length of a marriage is eight
years and so you're already being still
married you're already above half of the
people
and and the chart if you look at the
chart it's pretty cut and dry it gets
the your chance of divorce goes up and
up and up the more partners you've had i
just don't believe it's happy
i just don't believe they're happy i'm
sorry probably but why wouldn't you
believe them if they're you're asking
them isn't it like believe it or not i
mean i mean i know but i can only go i
could only go off things like my parents
relationship
they stayed married until my mom died do
it do i think they were happy but it's
but it's not about happiness it's about
duty
like it's so do you think everyone
should live their lives on duty yes oh
my gosh yeah especially if you have kids
okay if you have kids that's a
difference it's not about you anymore
it's about the family structure so even
even if they get divorced later in life
like that's still too like because i'm
thinking most of my me and my siblings
are out of the house right because my
parents have there's
they're my parents i'm one of ten right
and my parents built a multi-million
dollar business together and a lot of
people think that it's just
sunshine and rainbows no there's years
they hated each other but they stuck it
out and found true love
and now they're happier than ever well i
mean and so it's like but a lot of times
women aren't willing to stick out the
years of unhappiness right well my mom
did
and pick up your mom shout out to him
you stay big up but no but hold on sorry
my dad's a great guy by the way
their marriage was
their marriage went on the rocks due to
bad bankruptcy and them going into
business together that was the issue
right um it's not that my dad's a bad
guy if anything i'm more of a daddy's
girl than i am a mummy's guy my mum's a
bit toxic but
what i saw from their relationship
being unhappy a lot of the time i think
had a massively negative effect due to
finances
due to yeah because that is the primary
reason that women live in relationships
as well yeah so the financial aspect
obviously is important but again
what's important to note here is that
your mom struggled with your dad and
obviously they ended it together and
that's about you say what as in your mom
passed but it was still together yeah
and that's a beautiful thing yeah we're
saying that more i'm just not sure they
were happy i don't know what does
happiness mean to you that like in the
context of a relationship like because
they managed to have kids
you know they stayed the relationship
together like what does happiness look
like for you
not what i saw with my mom and my dad
so then what does it look like to you
then
what would you what would make you feel
happy in a relationship
um
i think what made me happy is to feel
like i have support it's feel like i
have
um to feel like i'm desired as well i'm
i'm i think that's really really
important i think it's you you have to
feel desired in a relationship otherwise
it's empty
and that's just my personality so
support and feeling desired that's what
happiness is to you
in
you do have to remember she has also
said like she can't have she's yeah i
can't when we're saying like the
commitment saying for the kids that like
she doesn't have that never had that in
fact i based all of my decisions on that
and i'm
forever regretful to be quite honest i
will be honest i i wish
that when i was
that when i found out
that i hadn't
told myself some of the things i told
myself to
sorry
i really wish i had i lied to myself i
did lie to myself to make myself feel
better about how that was gonna go down
and
um
and i think that
i don't think i would have probably
um
received so much of the pain in her like
i'm agreeing with the whole premise of
yeah too many sexual partners
but i don't think virginal you know what
i mean there's somewhere in between
right i went too far the other way
because i couldn't have children
i imagine if i could have had children
i'd have been more careful i'd have been
more careful about who i picked you know
i'm not disagreeing isn't that the
important message you should be telling
girls though because like
trying to strike for this in between
like i understand your situation
i can try and understand it but
if we're trying to create a better
society yeah and we've seen the
consequences of these actions based on
the stats and how people live
then doesn't it make sense to tell
younger girls this is the proper way to
behave to mitigate against these
feelings yeah well but at the same at
this on the same token this is what i
just have a problem with it because i i
think there's
and okay so we can all say it starts
with mothers right we can we can all say
you know mothers teach the boys how to
act as well but i think if you're gonna
say girls need to in the name of
feminism destroying marriages we also
need to be teaching men how to be men
and i just don't think that's happening
yeah because we need we need men to be
in relationships but if women are
leaving the men where's the man going to
teach the son because we live in a
society that's become more organocentric
it's more female-led which means that
most men as you mentioned are becoming
more feminine most men aren't leaders
and that's a consequence of the
breakdown of the nuclear home so if we
want to fix the nuclear home we need to
tell women
to stay with the men well they're not
staying with them and how they're going
to raise better men so long as it's not
a toxic environment for the children for
you if you're there with the kid like if
you're there with the partner you know
there is situations where like i you
know my mom sorry like i grew up and saw
my mum beaten like that was not good for
me and that is why i am the way i am
because i refuse point blank i'm like
absolutely not not dealing with it do
you know what i mean so in those
situations i do not think it's good
but i do think it is you know if there's
a stable relationship then every child
needs that yeah well and i i agree i
don't think someone should stay through
abuse but like to me that that's the
exception it's not the rule yeah i don't
think i don't think the majority of men
are out here abusing women but a lot of
times that's that's the narrative that i
hear from the media is that men are the
problem men are men are trash men are
abusive men cheat all the time when it's
just not it's not true the numbers don't
support it i think women are the problem
and not in a horrible way i'm not you
know going against women but i do think
we
oh sorry i do think us as women like you
say we are the ones doing the choosing
and we consistently choose the same
thing over and over and over and over
again like i'm good with it myself like
i do all the time my mom will literally
look at me like what you knew what you
were going into why have you done it and
it's like we have to change our way of
thinking but wouldn't the solution be to
get families back involved in the
vetting process
in some respects yeah i mean i would
quite happily have my dad tell me who
she thinks i have marathons
because my mom clearly didn't make a
very good choice in my eyes okay and in
that you know i grew up and i didn't
think she made a good choice but my